Tổ chức ý tệ thế giới về kênh hát ô người hem đặt trong năm 2018 đang phối hợp với cơ quan nghen kiểu ý tệ
có ra của cộng hòa dễ trụ công gồm mà dọng quy mô xen nhẹn bi đốt e bố la nhằm nhénh trọng
kìm xóa tởi tụng phát dịch đang lanzoc tại nước này. Tổng giảm đốc về kênh hát ô hộng
tệ droat givuy già xóa trởi e, chính dịch tập trung tăng cường mạng lời phòng thím nhé, cùng tấp gií liệu thời gian thật và phát hiện sớm
tất cả nghiệm để hát chế số gà từ bông. Hông tệ droat s cùng gà tới tổng mạng dưới trụ công gồm.
Trong bố gà bị kết hát ô cạnh báo đưa cụ phó hiện nay đâm phử quả khả nặn phó thuân cầu.
Hơ mừng nghe gà nghe giấm và sáng nhận mắt e bố la đã được vi nhận tại công gà dễ trụ công gồm
đậu gà đà khi tinh nhất 2,5 mươi chủ hiệu ổ cộng mạng dưới trụ công gồm từ bông.
Nó dịch nay, đến quan đến chuẩn mẹ bố la bố đi bố geo hiếm gặp hiện cho có hoặc xin và thuốc điều chỉ đã hiểu.
Chúng mình có dịch lãng dòng, u gà đá đạng đóng cờ bình dưới về công hà dẫn chủ công gồm,
dù về kết hạ ô cho rằng bế pháp này có thể kể phát đậm gượt biến trải phát giả tăng và làm dịch bệnh họ kiểm soát hưởng nếu á
Mỹ hành quốc và nhiều nước khác đẳng sích chặt các bạn phát phòng dịch.
Cụ thể Washington tăng cường xa lọc nhập cảnh và sẹp sét lập cơ sơ gạc liy tại Kenya cho câu dần Mỹ,
kổi định về nước thì cho phí con hành quốc mà dòng kìm dịch bệnh người tới các khu dạc còn quyết cơ cao
đồng thời nân cao năng lực tương phó hình gấp trong nước.